you've got their coordinates and matches
there I hope and you can see as in
previous times when I'm trying to
illustrate something often I don't need
the whole Cartesian plane for the
purpose of what we're doing today I'm
destroying the first and the second the
first one where X's and Y's are both
positive the second one where Y is still
positive but X is negative it cuz it's
to the left of you okay great now
they're heading is parallel and
perpendicular lines will do parallel
lines really quickly and then we're
going to spend our time and for most of
it on perpendicular ones that's where
most the actions
okay so I want you to have a look at
these two lines that I've got on here
from the origin up to eight and then
these are renovating over here and you
can see they are both parallel will be
like a nice sort of um one sentence
definition or even a are just a plain
language way to describe what is it that
makes parallel lines parallel yeah lines
definitely okay to line that can never
meet it's not a bad idea I will point
out though that even though it's a good
rule alone but how we work is a teeny
real problem like at the definition that
worked for us today but if we go further
it won't work example two lines here we
go if these rulers went on forever with
these lines ever meet and Sarno's but
are they parallel answer also no right
so we actually call these skew lines
naturally we don't look at things like
this very much because we are in how
many dimensions in sorry well we're in
three dimensions which is what let me do
this but we're working primarily in two
dimensions so the never meet idea is not
bad here it's not the best definitions
oh did someone give me another one that
might be parallel similar to that and
you can say mean whisper
okay so this is the more technical
definition that gets out something we've
been using recently and I'd love it all
right with me actually parallel lines
parallel line because I wanted sorry
parallel line share the same slope
slow of course being a synonym for
gradient okay so if you have a look at
these two you can probably just make out
if you squint a little bit better grid
here okay if every grid line represented
one unit could someone tell me what's
the gradient of a looks to me like to
the way we can calculate that is what is
the gradient formula again it's what
ever was I've ever run you can see this
rise looks like it's four and the run is
to 4 divided by 2 degrees by the way
that number two another thing it also
means is that every time you go across
one unit you go up two that's what the
good in fact let me just quickly draw
that you don't have to put this on so
just so you can visualize it you go
across one unit can you make that purple
arrow keys there
then you go up two and you're still on
the line and you can do it again you go
across one and then you go up to you can
do it anywhere you like as well you
don't have to put it on like nice neat
coordinates what will happen if I just
rewind a little bit let's start like
here it's like some weed oh why cause
fight in the middle of nowhere if I go
across one year run then how much drives
it's still two like that difference
there that I've done on that variable
arrow still the same because they're
laid even same all the way okay so we've
got rise over run
we know how it goes across so you can
see now let's get rid of constructions
the thing that makes this guy parallel
is that it also has that same gradient
of two goes from 1 up 2 cross 1 up to xn
all right parallel lines they're not to
create by the way the word power
it means alongside so Paranormal
Activity it's like it's not quite normal
it's sort of a bit over here parabola
you know those shapes it means drawing
something aside which is the shape you
get when you throw something away moving
it around
so what we do in house
I'm always getting greedy so the what it
sells parallel means it's going outside
you see it's not just that they never
meet it's also that they stay together
almost as it were